[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it
is the bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international
pastor doug batchelor well a blessed new
year folks
and welcome to bible answers live for
another year and we'd like to start with
an amazing fact
she's certainly one of history's most
famous women
with more schools churches hospitals and
people named for her
than any other person she's inspired
countless pieces of art
literature as well as sublime music and
songs
yet she speaks fewer than 200 words in
scripture
and we know comparatively little about
her so why is mary
worshiped by millions around the world
stay with us friends we're going to
learn more
on this edition of bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
okay friends welcome once again to bible
answers live and this is our first
program
of 2021 and we are live and we encourage
you to call in with your bible questions
we've some somehow we've survived 2020
and uh by the grace of god the gospel is
still good news and we're going to do
our best to answer your bible related
questions in this broadcast
it's a free phone call you just simply
call us at 800-463-7297
that's 800 god says we're also streaming
on
facebook and you can take a look at
doug batchelor's facebook page or the
amazing facts facebook page
but with your bible questions lines are
open now 800
god says 800-463-7297
and i am doug batchelor my name is john
ross good evening friends and happy new
year
happy new year to everyone i'm pastor
doug let's start with the word of prayer
dear father once again we are grateful
that we're able to take time at the
beginning of this
new year to kind of set a compass true
north and that is on your word and so we
pray for your guidance and your blessing
in jesus name amen
amen pastor you opened the program
talking about uh
mary mary the mother of jesus because
we've just come through the christmas
season and there's a lot of
discussion about mary and joseph and
baby jesus
but it is interesting that in um the
recent uh
address of the pope the new year sort of
address
he really emphasized mary in a in a way
that well
you don't really find it in the bible
that's right and you know first i want
to just say
to be very clear that there's no doubt
that mary was
a godly woman and chosen by god with an
ex
extraordinary responsibility as was
joseph for that matter
but over the years and the centuries and
millennia
there has been a mysticism that has
grown up around mary that she never
would have proved of that is not
endorsed by the bible
that she should be basically deified and
that means
that we should make you know a god out
of her now the bible talks about we've
got the
the trinity of god the father son and
holy spirit
but it's almost as though some dear folk
are exalting married to the point where
now you have a holy quartet
and she is you know being brought up to
this divine level
um pope francis for example during his
first
address in the new year he recited his
angelus um
message and he was focusing on the
importance of entrusting ourselves to
the motherly gaze of mary
through whom all is possible
and placing ourselves under the maternal
loving gaze of mary most
holy the pope explained in his daily
liturgy to celebrate mary as the mother
of god
now nowhere in the bible this is a bible
program again i want to emphasize
there's no question that mary is a godly
woman i look forward to
seeing her in the kingdom but nowhere in
scripture are we told that we should
pray to mary or look to mary
we certainly should not be bowing down
to statues to mary
the bible says do not make any images of
of anything in the heaven above earth
beneath let alone
of a personage and then bow before them
and even as the pope
gave this address he stood before a
statue of mary
and so you know idolatry is one of the
things the bible specifically
new and old testament says christians
should shun
and so this is all this you know
deifying of mary and
praying to mary this all basically
encourages something that the ten
commandments says should be avoided
and i think people some listening right
now just a lot of lovely
catholic and orthodox folks that have
maybe been
brought up to just love this you know
person that they
they hear about and but it's not a bible
teaching
and that shocks them if we do have a
book it's called the mystery of mary
and we'll be happy to send this out to
anyone who calls and asks and
this is our free offer this evening if
you'd like to get it the number is
800-835-6747
that is our resource phone line and as
for the book it's called the mystery of
mary
we also have a website that discusses
this further it's called
mary truth.com and you can just go to
that right now if you're close to your
computer
mary truth.com there's just some great
material there
a lot of bible verses and i think you'll
be encouraged as you take a look at that
marytruth.com
well pastor doug i think we're ready for
the phone lines our first call we have
is steven listening in canada stephen
welcome to the program
hi pastor doug hi
um hi uh first samuel 16
14 says the spirit of the lord has
departed from saul
and an evil spirit from the lord
tormented him
and the bible says god is light and in
him there is no darkness or evil
so how could an evil spirit from the
lord torment saul
and why does he use an evil spirit
well if if god turns out
light in a room the automatic response
is for darkness to fill the vacuum
and if you read in this passage if you
go back one verse
to verse so let's see we can go to verse
then samuel took the horn of oil and
anointed him that's
david in the midst of his brothers and
the spirit of the lord came upon
david from that day forward and then you
read in the next verse but the spirit of
the lord departed from saul
saul had grieved away god's spirit and
so when
the spirit of the lord is withdrawn
basically what's happening is
then you know god's allowing a vacuum to
come
and to fill it you know pastor ross you
know that verse if they receive not a
love of the truth god will send them
delusion that they should believe a lies
that
after first or second thessalonians that
i forget pastor ross is looking up a
verse for me but does that help at all
stephen
yes um but does that mean that god sends
us an evil spirit sometimes
no well no i don't believe that god is
sending a spirit he's basically
you look at the story of job and when
the devil came to god
he was maligning and accusing job and
god and saying god isn't fair you're
protecting job and god said all right
i'm going to give you permission to
harass job with a little certain limits
so basically god must withdraw his
angels that protect us
the bible says the angel of the lord
encamps around about those who fear him
so god when he withdraws the protection
the automatic thing then
is that the devils are going to come in
and so you could say well
the lord you know sent a spirit well he
didn't really send the spirit he just
withdrew his protection and the devils
came in
the verse you're referring to his second
thessalonians chapter 2 verse 11.
it says because they don't receive a
love of the truth that they might be
saved
for this reason god will send them a
strong delusion that they should believe
a lie that they all might be condemned
so there again it almost seems as though
it's the lord sending the spirit but
if the lord does not protect and he
withdraws his protection
there's only one other power that'll
come in and that's the devil right it
says they
receive not a love of the truth so they
are rejecting truth
what is the only other alternative when
you reject truth
you will then receive a lie so here it
says god
sends them a delusion that means you
know god's allowing delusion to come
same thing with king saul when he
rejected the holy spirit and the spirit
came on david
the only thing left when you reject the
spirit of god is for the darkness
to come in and god then allowed the evil
spirits to take saul
he didn't want that he wanted to fill
stall with his spirit
but saw through his pride and
stubbornness he rejected the lord
okay happy new year and please say hi to
bonnie for me
i will hey thanks so much steven she
might be listening right now
you take care bye now bye bye
all right we've got uh cole listening
from north dakota cole welcome to the
program
you might have only might have your mute
on
i do have a mute on oops um
hello i'm colin i'm asking about first
peter
three i'll start from it's mainly on
first peter 3 19 but i'll read
basically the context of 18-20 i can
read that
okay for christ also suffered once for
sins
that just for the unjust that he might
bring us to god
being put to death in the flesh but made
alive by the spirit
by whom also he went and preached to the
spirits in prison
who formerly were disobedient when once
the divine long suffering waited in the
days of noah
while the ark was being prepared in
which a few that is
eight souls were saved through water
okay
so you want to know what that verse
means yeah i'm kind of confused on that
one i mean i guess
i've had it kind of on some people you
know believe kind of like an immortal
soul type thing
speaking to or who is he speaking to
what are those all right spirits
yes do you have your you got your bible
there
um i want you to look in
if you look in genesis chapter 6
verse 3 it tells us well actually the
first verse is it says that
when the sons of god saw the daughters
of men this is the descendants of seth
intermarried with the descendants of
cain they weren't supposed to marry the
unbelievers
that the wickedness filled the world and
you read in verse 5 the lord saw
wickedness of man was great in the earth
but look at what it says in verse 3
god says my spirit will not always
strive with man
so this is just before the flood god
says his spirit would not always strive
with man
then you go back to that verse there in
peter and he's basically saying
that if
when they rejected the spirit of god
then evil took over the world and it's
not saying that jesus went down
to hell and preached
during that time of darkness it's
basically saying
that the people who were imprisoned by
sin
during that time um
were in bondage to sin and through the
holy spirit
through noah he preached to him god said
my spirit will not always strive with
man that's back in genesis chapter six
his days will be 120 years so for 120
years the spirit of god strove with the
people
pled with them through the preaching of
noah but only eight souls were saved
so does that make sense it's not saying
that a person dies or that jesus died
and he went
to preach to people and give them
another chance
okay that one i've kind of heard of it
like that
but um it didn't seem right to me so
that's why i thought i'd ask then i
had some asked some a pastor of mine and
he gave me a lot of information has
a lot to digest at the moment so um
thank you
all right hope that helps a little
appreciate your call cole we've got
chris listening for florida chris
welcome to the program
yes thank you pastors um i have another
question about
the holy spirit okay and i'm sorry
i don't understand what was the role
uh can you explain help me understand
in in the new testament we know that the
believer
once uh the believer is um
is filled with holy spirit the holy
spirit doesn't leave
him is it correct you're wondering about
the spirit of god then in the old
testament
yes what role of was of the holy spirit
in the old testament yes the role of the
holy spirit in the old testament
is really the same as the role of the
holy spirit in the new testament
you can read right there in genesis the
spirit of god was in the beginning
moving on the face of the waters
king david prays in psalm 51 take not
thy holy spirit from me
you can read in numbers where god took
the spirit from moses and placed it on
the 70 elders
and they began to prophesy just like you
get to acts and it tells us that christ
places hands on the apostles and
uh earlier than that and in the upper
room he breathed on him and said receive
the holy spirit
and you've got the spirit of elijah
coming upon elisha
and so you've got the the spirit of the
lord came on samson the spirit of the
lord came on david and so
you've got the working of the holy
spirit through new and old testament
you don't have the full baptism of the
holy spirit until you get to
acts chapter 2. but the spirit of god
we're striving with people as i
mentioned to our former caller
all through scripture now we do have a
book on the holy spirit too we can send
you chris
if you've not seen that yet you still
there
yeah yes yes i am yeah
we do have a book that's called it's
actually on the trinity pass today we
might also have one on the holy spirit
called life in the spirit but we have a
book
called the trinity and uh we'll be happy
to send this to anyone who calls and
asks the number is 800 835
seven four seven and again we have two
free offers two books the ones on the
trinity
the other one talks about the spirit i
think it's life in the spirit is what
it's entitled
we'll be able to send either one of
those to anyone who calls
and asks we've got elizabeth listening
from new york elizabeth welcome to the
program
hello hi thank you for your ministry
i have a question about
body piercing and tattoos what does the
bible have to say about that
well there's one verse that's pretty
clear if you read this
this would be the new king james version
i think several other versions
leviticus 19 28 you shall not
make any cuttings in your flesh for the
dead or tattoo any marks on you
i am the lord the bible tells us in the
new testament that your body is the
temple of the holy spirit
now i realize even as i say this if
there's a lot of folks who are listening
in their homes or driving down the road
and their eyebrows just went up and they
thought man
tattoos are ubiquitous now everybody's
getting tattoos and there's tattoo
parlors
uh you know on every corner practically
um
but even though it's uh just become
a norm god says that you know our bodies
he doesn't want us putting graffiti it's
you know it's one thing that kids are
kind of
painting them their face like a clown at
a carnival and they go home wash it off
but tattoos are it's kind of making a
permanent
mutilation or mark in your body same
thing with
whether you're making cuttings or
putting poking holes in your body
god doesn't want us to mutilate our
bodies uh
he made our bodies with the right number
of holes in the beginning i don't think
he wants us to add or subtract event
and uh or it was a common custom in
pagan worship the prophets of baal lept
on the altar and
cut themselves and then you read about
the man in
mark chapter five who's demon-possessed
and he cut himself with stones and
there's people struggling with mental
illness today that uh they it's not
mental illness it's
it's really just a um a specific problem
of cutting
and no god wants us to take care of our
bodies
i'm happy to hear that i had questions
well thank you so much yeah now the only
exception to that
is that when a male boy was eight days
old
and he was to go through the right of
circumcision that was the only cutting i
know of in the bible that they said they
allowed
at that time all right well thank you
for your quality elizabeth we've got
noah listening in illinois no welcome to
the program
thank you for having me dog aaron jane
yeah
pastor ross hi yeah your question
my question is is was there like
specific dog breeds
on noah's ark yeah chihuahua
i believe that noah was told to take two
of each species so you know you may not
have had
20 different kinds of cats i think there
was one
lion-like cat and all of the bigger and
smaller cats
have you know come from that and i think
there were two
when i said one cat i mean one species
there was a male and a female and there
was probably
two dogs and it's interesting national
geographic did a
a dna backtrack on dogs
and they said all modern dogs the dna of
all modern dog breeds today can be
traced back to
a very large wolf-like dog or in two of
them
and that was probably more like a wolf
or a husky
and yeah all the different
breeds of human in the world traced back
to
adam and eve and then again to noah and
his wife
so yeah i don't think god didn't need
noah to take
you know 12 different species of sheep
or horse or
giraffes and there's one type in these
categories
okay thank you all right thanks so much
believe it or not
a chihuahua and a great dane are both
dogs and you can cross them
i don't know what you get a gateway
a great one i don't know what it is but
yeah there's only two all right let's
get some more questions we got shannon
in michigan shannon welcome to the
program
hi good evening i'm wondering um hey
uh are moses and elijah in
heaven i wonder if you could clarify for
me yeah you read in second kings chapter
that god took elijah up to heaven in a
whirlwind
and then if you read in mark chapter 9
it says both elijah and moses appeared
to jesus
on this mount of transfiguration and
moses it's believed that the lord raised
him
three days now this is not in the bible
but there's uh
some ancient jewish writings
that was called the assumption of moses
it's referred to by i think early church
father named origen the original copies
aren't around anymore and it says that
after god after moses was laid to rest
god buried him and three days later he
raised him
now you do find in the book of jude i
think it's verse
9 that when michael the angel comes to
resurrect moses
that he has a dispute with the devil
actually he won't dispute the devil he
simply says
the lord rebuke thee so
there is evidence that moses was raised
and elijah was raised and they are in
heaven now
all right thank you so much all right
thanks so much for your question
hey pastor ross we do have a book on
that called the two witnesses it's a
great book
we'll send you a free copy we'll be able
to send this to you shannon or anyone
who would like to receive that just ask
for the book it's called the two
witnesses
the number is 800-835-6747
and again ask for that free offer we've
got samuel listening in tennessee samuel
welcome to the program
hello pastor doug hi how are you
yeah doing all right first off i'd like
to say
thank you and thank you uh gene ross
for all the hard work that you have done
well thank you it's been a blessing it's
hard to believe we've been going about
26 years with this program now
yeah all right wow um my
my question for you is is the
nebula of orion the the gateway to
heaven
well the bible doesn't specifically say
that a number of christian astronomers
and some commentators believe
that if you want to know where in the
heavens you would find the dwelling
place of god there are three is it three
yeah there's three places in the bible
where orion is mentioned two of them are
in job
and one of them is in amos job 9 9
job 38 31 and amos 5
8 and it talks about can you loose the
belt of orion
he made the bear orion and the pleiades
and then amos says he made the pleiades
and orion he turns the shadow of death
into mourning
so in the northern hemisphere they often
looked at that section of the skies
and they i think some of the early
christians believed that
the place of god's dwelling was through
a corridor up there but
there's no scripture that really says
that and of course just to add to that
we know in the bible that deliverance
often comes from the east
it speaks jesus himself said the second
coming would be as
lightning that shines from the east even
to the west right so also shall the
coming of the son of man be
orion can be observed in the northern
hemisphere but also in the southern
hemisphere okay
i didn't know that because it's kind of
in the middle and it's enough to the
east
so yeah it seems like you look at for
example in the bible you have
deliverance of israel
when they were in captivity uh sometimes
deliverance would come
from the east uh revelation speaks about
uh deliverance coming from the east or
judgment from the east so
yeah you put all of that together it
appears to be that the second coming
comes christ comes from the east the
direction of orion
interesting yep i'd put an x on the sky
and keep watching
all right hey thanks so much samuel
appreciate your question
all right we've got diane listening in
arizona diane welcome to the program
hello you two happy new year hope it's
going to be a better year this year
um i got a quick i got a quick question
in revelation the angels the third
angel's message okay i have a question
on the second
that the angel said babylon has fallen
has fallen
i don't think it's literally but can you
explain it to me
sure yeah i'll jump in and pass it like
you can add you know babylon is given
or at least the name babylon is used in
revelation
for a woman that's described in
revelation 17
and a woman in bible prophecy represents
a church
so here is a religious system that the
bible describes as being
fallen it's interesting to note that
babylon you have babylon the mother
but you also have daughters so these
would be churches that buy
into the doctrines or the teachings of
the mother church
it's also interesting that you have two
falls babylon he's fallen is fallen
there is a fall of the mother there is
the fall of the daughters
so the daughter churches would be those
who have set aside bible teaching for
man-made tradition
and of course we find that beginning
during the dark ages even before the
dark ages many pagan
ideas and teachings finding their way
into the christian church
and this is what the second angel is
warning about it's warning about these
these false
teachings false doctrines that we find
not just in catholicism but
some of the teachings they've even found
their way into protestant churches
so there is there is the warning um we
need to come out of this religious
confusion
make us stand upon the teachings of the
bible
yep okay well thank you very much
and have a happy new year a better year
with jesus amen hey thanks so much diane
thanks for your call our next caller
that we have is uh
daria listening from the bahamas dario
welcome to the program
hi thank you for having me thank you and
make sure and speak up because you're
calling from a long way okay
no problem um my question is
is it deceptive to show an inaccurate
representation
of jesus especially when we know that it
creates
specifically for certain races doubt of
who he is and what his
mission was on earth yeah
so you're talking about if someone
portrays like a picture of jesus
yeah that's correct especially you know
obviously obviously in
books and magazines and presentations
right
you know that's a good question i'm glad
you asked that um you know
i've i've struggled with this myself
because
pastor ross and i we travel you do
evangelistic programs we often use
slides
if we prepare a slide program in north
america it is typically going to depict
something like the traditional view of
jesus
with you know hazel hair and and uh
you know brown or blue eyes and uh and
then if you go to india it makes it a
little more difficult
for them to relate and we've done
meetings and uh we've been to india
together in africa and
australia and everywhere you go you know
people have a little different spin on
jesus and so
it's always nice if you can be sensitive
to that sometimes though you struggle
with finding
artists representations and so
but it does always help when you're
doing evangelistic art
in your presentations if you if you have
artwork
that will be relatable by you know to
the various cultures that you're in
but that said you know it is fairly
certain that jesus
looked like a galilean jew or a
uh yeah he lived up in galilee but they
probably all look the same all through
the land of israel
and he must have mingled in looking like
just about everybody else because
even judas needed to identify him by
betraying him with a kiss
the guards couldn't figure out which one
was jesus he looked like everyone else
anyway hey thanks so much for your
question
daria we're gonna have to take a break
right now friends don't go away this is
just a break we've got uh the best bible
questions i see you lined up and ready
we're coming back in just a few moments
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
in six days god created the heavens and
the earth
for thousands of years man has
worshipped god on the seventh day of the
week
now each week millions of people worship
on the first day
what happened why did god create a day
of rest
does it really matter what day we
worship who is behind this great shift
discover the truth behind god's law and
how it was changed
visit sabbathtruth.com
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
did you know that noah was present at
the birth of abraham
okay maybe he wasn't in the room but he
was alive
and probably telling stories about his
floating zoo
from the creation of the world to the
last day events of revelation
biblehistory.com is a free resource
where you can explore
major bible events and characters
enhance your knowledge of the bible
and draw closer to god's word go deeper
visit biblehistory.com
what if you could know the future
what would you do
[Music]
what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past
alexander the great becomes king when
he's only 18 but he's a
military prodigy 150 years in advance
cyrus had been named rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
the gospel writers see his death as
a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted by pastor
doug batchelor
explores the most striking bible
prophecies that have been dramatically
fulfilled throughout history
kingdoms in time get your copy today
available now on dvd blu-ray or usb
for more information visit kingdoms in
time dot com
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god
and his plan to save you so what are you
waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life
today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live welcome back
listening friends to
bal bible answers live a blessed new
year to all of you
and we are going to be taking your bible
questions without much delay
uh if you want to call in once again 800
god says
800-463-7297
with your bible questions lines are open
and the number
if for our free offers is also up on the
screen
if you go to facebook and that would be
the doug batchelor facebook page or the
amazing facts facebook page you can see
what's going on
in the studio here i always wonder why
anyone would want to but people do
seem to like tuning in to watching radio
and so you're welcome to join us uh via
facebook as well
i am doug batchelor my name is john ross
and pastor just maybe to add to that we
are excited this new year our hope
and it looks like it's coming together
is to um
expand bible answers live that it's not
only a radio program but it actually
becomes a
a weekly television program television
broadcast
yes and we're looking to use amazing
facts tv and maybe even some other
outlets
to broadcast so stay tuned friends not
only would you be able to hear us but
we want to try and get this program in
the air yeah we'll try and make it
even i think a little more interactive
where you might even be able to zoom in
some of the questioners
and get them involved all right we've
got let's see luke is listening in
minnesota
luke welcome to the program good evening
gentlemen how are you
doing good your question tonight
so i have a question about um ezekiel
chapter 38
um kind of spilling into 39.
verse eight seems to
in my opinion point towards the latter
days
um and then verse 20
talks about all the men of the earth
talk about uh 20 are you talking about
39 or 38 verse 20 chapter
chapter 38 verse 8 um
seems to me to to point towards um
the fulfillment of israel become
re-becoming a nation
the verse about the sundial going down
no this is ezekiel uh
oh okay i misunderstood i think our
screener put down
isaiah so that that's through us both i
got it okay
great great that now it's making sense
let me read verse 8 just so we get the
context for those who are listening
without without uh
their bible it says ezekiel 38 8 and
after many days
you will be visited and in the latter
years you will come again into the land
of those who brought you back
from the sword and gathered from many
people on the mountains of israel
which had long been desolate they might
be brought out of the nations
and now all of them dwell safely
so you're wondering if is this is this
prophecy referring to
a historical event or is it referring to
something yet in the future
well i was wondering if there was
something in the future because
um it seems to me
that um you know it goes through a list
of a lot of different
places that will rise up against israel
and in verse 11 it talks about i will go
up against a land of unwalled villages
and i will go to a peaceful people who
dwell safely
all of them dwelling without walls and
having neither bars nor gates
um in my opinion i don't think that
that's ever really happened
in the history of israel as a nation
yeah
i think you're looking the key here is
at the very beginning of chapter 38
it says gog in the land of magog
that takes you to revelation 20 which is
future
correct yep
and and so i guess going through like in
um chapter or verse 20 of 38
it talks about um you know all the men
on the face of the earth and the
mountains will be thrown down and the
steep places will fall
but yet in 39 it talks about the burial
of
gog and it says that the israelites will
for seven months bury them
yeah all right you know i think
i'm sorry go ahead no so i i guess
you know like i understand like in the
end times that you know there will be a
great earthquake
um which is spoken of um
in verse in verse 19 of chapter 38
that there's going to be a great
earthquake but
then you have a seven month time period
following that earthquake
i think the key to understanding
ezekiel 38 and 39
is revelation 20 it's describing a time
following the millennium where all of
the wicked who've ever lived and that
names all these nations that were the
historic
enemies of israel are going to come
against the city of god they represent
the lost of all ages
the wicked of all ages they come against
the people of god
who are saved they're in the new
jerusalem
and they launched this final attack
and it says that you know satan he rises
up against them and god reigns fire down
out of heaven and devours them
and then there there is a period of time
where they're being destroyed
yeah let me read that passage because uh
it kind of goes along with it says
now when the thousand years were
finished satan was released from his
prison and he went out to deceive the
nations
which were on the four corners of the
earth gog and magog there we have that
phrase
to gather them to battle the numbers as
the sand of the sea
and they went up in the breadths of the
earth surrounded the camp of the saints
the beloved city
that would be the new jerusalem fire
came down from god out of heaven and
devoured them
so this is the final great battle or the
showdown
between the forces the good forces of
evil and yes
it occurs at the end of that 1000 year
period so there is a
great resurrection that takes place at
the end of the millennium end of the
thousand years
you know we do have a study guide that
gets into this in more detail and it's
called a thousand years of peace
and it's all about the millennium
touches a little bit on gog and magog
and
the battle at the end so we'll be happy
to send this to you luke or anyone
wanting to learn more about these
fascinating prophecies as for the study
guide it's called a thousand years of
peace
the number is 800-835-6747
and we'll get that in the mail and send
it off to you yeah another key
verse here it says i will bring him to
judgment with pestilence and bloodshed i
will rain down on him and his
troops and many people flooding rain
hail and brimstones which is the same
thing you find in revelation 20.
yeah it says they cover the earth like a
cloud so anyway yeah i think that that
unfolds here the seven months that could
be a symbolic term for just the judgment
seven is often a time for
you know the cleansing but uh big study
it's hard to study two chapters in a
quick
bible question hey thank you so much
yeah
all right we've got ross listening in
california ross welcome to the program
good name thank you
i was wondering uh what was the lifespan
of adam and eve and moses
abraham and noah i think you already
told me about no 120 years
well the the time that noah preached is
120 years the bible tells us that adam
lived 930 years it does not give the age
of eve there's very few women in the
bible where it gives their age
i think we can figure the age of of
sarah was
was 120 or 127 years i think it does
give her
age but um abraham lived 175 years
moses lived 120 years noah lived
i think 965 years
um yeah they're uh
they've they lived uh centuries before
the flood then after the flood their
lives quickly
shortened yeah noah lived 900 and uh 50
years
50 years i'm sorry okay yeah it was
methuselah in 969
is that right yep so
anyway hope that helps a little ross i
was wondering is something else in
my king james version bible that says
job's names
in the front and the context just says
j-o-b
but i think i saw unless i just imagined
it
it's j-o-b-e yeah there's both spellings
and the english took job
and matter of fact if you're from
england and your name is job
you'll spell it j-o-b-e um but
we you know in an american you say i'm
applying for a job
j-o-b and so job was j-o-b-e it's a
little different pronunciation but the
old
english typically still spells at j.o.b
i
i heard a uh i remember hearing a
preacher that was a self-taught preacher
and he was preaching from the book of
job and he just
sat there and listened to his whole
sermon about job
[Laughter]
so all right hey thanks so much ross
we've got uh robert listening
in washington robert welcome
welcome to you too welcome back and
happy new year
thank you likewise and your question
tonight
uh hebrews 13 i i sometimes
as i'm talking online with different
peoples um
they'll tell me that the ten
commandments are obsolete and
not valid anymore and they like to use
this verse hebrews 8 13.
hebrews 8 13. okay
i believe yeah well let's take a look
here
it says and in that he says a new
covenant he has made the first obsolete
now what is becoming obsolete is growing
old and ready to vanish away and that's
absolutely true
the old covenant is not the ten
commandments
the old covenant is the agreement a
covenant is an agreement it's
a contract and the agreement is based
upon things
now the old covenant was an agreement
that the people said all the lord has
said we will do
they agreed to keep the ten commandments
uh the new covenant god said i'm gonna
take my law same commandments he said
i'm gonna put them in your heart
and i will it's based on the promises of
god the old covenant is faulty based
upon the promises of the people
the new covenant is based on the promise
of god but god has not
thrown out the ten commandments where
now christians are no longer
obligated to be honest or not murder
and the other you know ten or eight
commandments beside them
well you know verse 10 i think really
clarifies what you're saying pastor like
it says for this is the covenant that
i'll make
with the house of israel after those
days i will put my laws
in their mind and write it in their
hearts so it's not
taking away the ten commandments but
rather it's taking the ten commandments
from tables of stone and putting it in
the heart
and of course the 10 commandments are
written in your heart you will keep
those
those laws a rich young ruler came to
jesus we just read this
this week and you can read this in mark
chapter 10
it's also in matthew said good master
what should i do to have eternal life
jesus said keep the commandments and so
we're not keeping them to be saved but
for the believer you keep them because
you are saved
and you want to please the lord we have
a special uh free offer we'll be happy
to give you robert that talks about
the uh why the old covenant failed yes
it's a great booklet by joe cruz
we'll send it to anyone wanting to learn
more about the new covenant what the
bible says
four 800-835-6747 asked for the book why
the old covenant failed again that's 800
835 67 47
brady's listening in atlanta georgia
brett welcome to the program
good evening pastors how are y'all sure
doing good thank you
good my question relates to matthew 5
32. um i'm divorced
and in a situation where my my child my
children and myself were being abused
my now wife is divorced in a situation
where
her husband never really left his
parents house to be a part of their
marriage
and so our concern is the part where it
says
committing adultery if if we're divorced
for any other reason other than adultery
so it's always complicated to
go deep into this question on the phone
because there's usually lots of um
a lot of details that can affect this
but i think you're saying that you're
divorced and you're remarried now
and the person you're remarried to also
has been divorced and you're wondering
am i getting this right you're wondering
if the bible is saying your marriage is
not valid
yes sir yes sir um
well biblically the only grounds for
divorce and remarriage is adultery
um some make a an argument that
abandonment
you know sometimes a man will marry a
woman have a couple of kids and he takes
off for ten years
at some point i think a christian would
uh
say that that person is they're not
coming back and
and they'd probably be free to have that
marriage annulled and remarry
um and then you've got also in first
corinthians seven
if two pagans are married and one
becomes a christian and the unbeliever
says look i'm divorcing you because i
didn't i didn't marry a christian i
don't want to be married to a christian
paul said in such cases let them depart
you should try to keep the marriage
together to have a sink to find
influence
especially if there's children but what
if
two people who maybe don't have biblical
grounds for divorce and remarriage
they do it and then they look at the
scripture and say oh now what do we do
should they then divorce and go back to
their original spouses well that's not
always practical and deuteronomy says
you can't do that or it defiles the land
and god doesn't want us wife swapping
and
going back it is a sin
it is not the unpardonable sin you have
that woman that jesus spoke to
in john chapter four he said you've had
five husbands and you're living with a
character you're not married to
but yet he revealed he was the messiah
you know understandably she could be
saved
david had no right to marry bathsheba
and he was punished for that sin but
later it says bathsheba was his wife
and they had a child together that ended
up being the king solomon so
you know they were forgiven but it was a
sin so you know my god kind of meets us
where we're
at and you can't unscramble scrambled
eggs i always say you should probably
talk to a good bible
based pastor that you can just you know
give them the details and
and ask for some counsel on that but
yeah i don't recommend if you're married
you get divorced now
you know we do especially if there's
children involved yeah we have a book
it's called
marriage divorce and remarriage and
we'll be happy to send this out um and i
think brett you'll find this very
helpful
the number is 800-835-6747 and again
just answer the book it's called
marriage divorce
and remarriage written by pastor deck a
lot of bible in there a lot of
scriptures so
you'll find that encouraging when you
read through that we got raymond
listening from
louisiana raymond welcome to the program
hi thank you so much i really appreciate
everything you guys are doing this is
actually my first time ever listening to
the program so i've been really enjoying
everything you guys have to offer we
hope it's habit forming thank you
yes yes absolutely um well listen i i
um long time christian lived in
hypocrisy for a long time
outwardly publicly uh portray the
christian
but behind closed doors
uh i have not uh i've lived a life of
hypocrisy
and i am repenting from those things um
and
i've been working through all that but
i'm having trouble with grace i'm having
trouble
not i have faith that god will can
forgive me but i'm i'm really struggling
with it and i'm
i'm i i'm just struggling to
deal with my sins i'm very ashamed i'm
very ashamed
i'm very shameful like and i'm just it's
really hard
well you know that that's a great
starting point if you weren't ashamed
i'd be worried
shame is that's the birthplace of
repentance it's sorrow for sin
and it's the sorrow for sin that
leads us to want to turn from sin and
the bible tells us that jesus came into
the world to save sinners and so
i think i'm hearing you freely admit
that you're a sinner and that you've
been a hypocrite
and praise god there's hope for the
hypocrite or there'd be no hope for
anybody
but jesus came to save sinners you
qualify
and so he certainly came to save you and
god is more willing to save you
than maybe you believe he's desperate to
save you
he loves us more than we love our
earthly children and though you may have
fallen seven times the bible says a
righteous man falls seven times and
rises again
god is very merciful he cast seven
devils out of mary magdalene
and so you know tell the lord you're
sorry
and he he knows you mean it tell him
you're weak
you know even peter followed jesus three
and a half years and then denied him
three times
and peter went out and he wept bitterly
he was ashamed
jesus said peter do you love me he says
i love you and jesus forgave him
and he not only forgave me put him back
to work so
just yeah really believe raymond now
we've got a book three steps to heaven
yep well actually there's two books i'm
thinking about pastor that's one
great book it's called three steps to
heaven one encourage you to call and ask
for that
is that another book that we don't
always hand out but it's great it's
called
is it possible to live without sinning
and it's an encouraging book
i mean we want to gain the victory is it
possible for a christian to
to gain that victory well that's
encouraging when you see what the bible
says on that
we'll be happy to send both to you if
you just call and ask anyone
we've got three steps to heaven is it
possible to live without sinning
the number to call is 800-835-6747
that's seven four 800-835-6747 just call
and ask for those books
and uh we'll get in the mail you know i
i want to
i'm gonna really complicate things i'm
gonna mention a third book for raymond
you mentioned grace
and we have a great book called riches
of his grace you can ask for that as
well
and i think you can read all three of
these for free online
right now if you want just head on over
to the amazing facts
website we have a a free online library
and uh you can kind of look through the
various books that we have there and
download the pdf absolutely
thanks for your call we got damon
listening from oklahoma city oklahoma
damon welcome to the program
hello how are you guys doing tonight
good
thank you your question yeah i was
wondering how to better explain um
making a connection with god still in
the sabbath
um usually when i try to do this i kind
of
go towards like speaking about the marks
and how
like the dragon gave the roman catholic
church
its power and connecting it in the sand
and showing them like you know the mark
of the roman catholic church their
authority is sunday
but god already has a day of worship
with the sabbath
but i kind of struggle making a
connection with god still in the sabbath
like explaining that well i'll tell you
what there's
if you look in let's talk about the seal
of god
everyone thinks about the mark of the
beast and you really need to be marked
by god to be saved
you read in isaiah chapter 8 bind up the
testimony
seal the law among my disciples
and in the ten commandments in the law
of god you find
one commandment that actually has the
word holy in it
and that is the sabbath commandment and
it's about
our time with god and time is what life
is made if god wants a love relationship
with us and so this is the seal you can
also read in ezekiel 9 about everybody
that is saved in ezekiel 9
there's a judgment on the house of god
but those that sigh and cry
for the sins they receive this mark the
seal that saves them it protects them
so take a look at ezekiel 9 i think
we've got a book that talks about
the um the seal of god and we'll be
happy to share that with you
again if you'd like to receive more
information about the seal of god of the
mark of the beast
we want to recommend our amazing facts
study guide series
there's actually two parts to it and
people might not know this and it's
available online we encourage you to
go ahead and sign up online or just call
and ask
we have the introductory set of lessons
but then this question talking about the
seal of god the mark of the beast is
part of our advanced
online bible course and the reason we're
encouraging you to do this there's a
whole lot of background
a lot of scripture it's a big subject an
important subject
we want to encourage folks to sign up
and take advantage of our free online
bible school
the number is 800-835-6747
enroll me in the amazing facts bible
school you can do it online or
you can subscribe we'll send you the
lessons you can
read through them fill it in send it
back to us and it will be a big
encouragement
we've got kathy listening in virginia
kathy welcome to the program
hi thank you hi and your
question um
forgive me i'm a little emotional i'm
sorry um okay
so jesus said if you had faith it's a
grain of mustard seed you know you can
ask and
i will give it to you and and the bible
says that if you have somebody sick and
you call them the elders of the church
and you have them anointed
um that the prayer of faith
shall save the sick doesn't say it might
does it say
if god's not on vacation it just says it
will but it
my mother was a wonderful godly actually
seventh-day adventist christian woman
and she believed and i believed and
she died a very miserable death
and i struggle with that a lot um
well and so there the promises of god in
the bible of course are
true when he says that the prayer of
faith will save the sick
um first of all you know sometimes a
person will get
up in age and typically we
we have problems with our health
even the prophet elisha who had a double
portion of elijah's spirit he died of a
lingering illness
here elijah goes to heaven in a fiery
chariot
but it didn't challenge his faith he
knew that god was working through that
paul who healed many people he had a
thorn in his side some medical
physical problem and he said lord three
times can you take it from me and god
god said yeah when you get to heaven but
not now
he said my strength is made perfect in
weakness and so
yes sometimes god does allow suffering
and
but it doesn't mean he's not answering
our prayers well you know i think you
mentioned the verse
the prayer of faith will save the sick
we often think of that in terms of now
but of course the greater meaning the
greater promise is that
there is going to be a resurrection
mourning and the dead in christ will
rise
first there'll be no more pain no more
sorrow sometimes god does extend a
person's life now
and we've seen it past the degree of
ministry in miraculous ways but
also there have been cases where we've
prayed for someone we've anointed them
with oil we've had faith and it's a
believer
and yet uh in god's will he
determines he sees best to lay them to
rest and
sometimes we have questions but you know
the amazing thing is
people who believe in christ and trust
in him even if they go through some
sickness or pain
they can be such a witness where other
people look at them and say do you still
believe
look you're struggling you're suffering
and yet their faith is strong
i wouldn't encourage that encouragement
that is to so many that's right
absolutely and kathy you said your first
your mother was a person of great faith
keep in mind
when she closes her eyes in death her
next conscious thought is
complete healing and a glorified body
and so that prayer is going to be
answered
when jesus comes he's giving her a
glorified body
no pain no sorrow no death and um but
you know
it it does break our hearts when we see
loved ones suffer i've seen it and
i think everyone listening don't let
that challenge your faith god is still
good
uh listening friends we probably
wouldn't be fair to take another
question i see
christy and edward and rick and diana
and julianna and sue
waiting to get your question answered i
don't think we're going to get to you
tonight
i hope you will give us another chance
next week
and we want to wish everybody a blessed
new year
i know there's still a lot of challenges
going on around the country
and whatever the problem is we still
believe that jesus is the answer
we'd encourage you to go to the amazing
facts website and you can
also be looking at listening to
these resources all through the year
we've got bible studies
we have sermon videos and after you
enjoy
them if you're being edified spiritually
pass it along to your friends
and if you are blessed we're 100
listeners supported
you know what that means just go to the
website and click donate
keep us on the air for another year and
we'll look forward to studying with you
next week
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible
even better than before bible answers
live is produced by amazing facts
international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay
california
the bible tells us that salvation of
course emanates from god
so we need to know something about god
to rightly understand and embrace
salvation
yet in the church today there's a great
deal of confusion about the nature of
god
the bible says god is one god but is he
three persons
is jesus also eternal god because jesus
is the son of god does that mean there
was a time when he did not exist or he
was brought into existence
is the holy spirit a person or is he
just
the force and the energy that god uses
to communicate
you know i thought this was so important
i really felt led of the lord to write a
book on the subject
called exploring the trinity one god or
three
in this book we answer those very
important questions we talk about the
history of the holy spirit
in the old testament as well as the
history of the holy spirit in the church
and how it has been much debated this is
something we really need to understand
because jesus said eternal life comes
from
knowing god can't get enough amazing
facts bible study
you don't have to wait until next week
to enjoy more truth-filled programming
visit the amazing facts media library at
aftv.org
at aftv.org you can enjoy video
and audio presentations as well as
printed material
all free of charge 24 hours a day seven
days a week right from your computer or
mobile device
visit aftv.org
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
did you know amazing facts has a free
bible school that you can do from the
comfort of your own home
it includes 27 beautifully illustrated
study lessons to aid in your study of
god's word
sign up today for this free bible study
course by calling
that's one eight 1-844-215-7000 four two
one five seven thousand
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfact
and sign up for our free bible study
course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800-835-6747
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org